the the first piece that i made uh with
this process uh was a was a really long
extended experiment i would tape it
together instead of making a commitment
to glue it together for i think i worked
on it for about three months just every
day continually just figuring out the
form
i pretty much have a false start i feel
like with every piece that i work on the
first piece had tons of false starts
i feel like there's a little demolition
on almost every single piece
and deciding what to sculpt a lot of
times i think of it as sort of like a
soupy equation and it might be something
that i read about
recently and something else i read about
and i started thinking about how these
two ideas might intersect with one
another
it might be something that i witnessed
going for a walk
it really comes from a lot of a lot of
very different sources of conversation
i don't necessarily have a like a fixed
objective i think it's just a matter of
keeping myself interested
i guess ultimately that's really what it
is it's about this exploration that i
keep digging into and finding more and
more avenues to explore